something beside me has always been and
I was awake
it's a second chapter in the trilogy so
we pick up where the force awakens left
off first awakens introduce these
characters it just for me instantly felt
alive and kind of part of the Star Wars
universe and now this middle chapter we
got to put them through the the meat
grinder test their mettle and see what
they're made out of for right there is
time to ask questions that she has been
harboring and time to sort of process
what has gone on in the force awakens
it's a roller coaster ride was
definitely something that challenges the
characters as I've said many many times
before it's just a darker version of a
story moving forward it's never
sacrificed for the spectacle of it the
familial dynamics I think between all of
them how much should reference his
friendship the characters I think it is
what keeps people interest I'm just
saying that cuz I met up but like from
from my experience of watching the
original trilogy's it's always the
people that kind of make you want to
re-watch those movies well it went away
for a long time but there was always
people that never let it die listen I
wait for big epics like King Kong to see
IMAX it's incomparable I mean it's
bigger the sound the seedings it's like
the ultimate movie experience it was
crazy to just see this scream that just
basically messes you into this world as
far as your eyes can can take you and I
think is the best Star Wars experience
go see it's freakin Star Wars bro it's
you know filmmaking on this scale it's
massive and it's also incredibly
beautiful and so intricate there's a lot
of really cool action sequences in this
movie and I think it's gonna be awesome
I can't wait to see it on Exile this is
the most brilliant form of sin
this film is going to knock it out the
park in the back sorry I make say just
myself too because it like sit down with
an audience and watch it on the big IMAX
screen with that sound booming at you I
need someone to show me my place in all
this
thank goodness we have IMAX
you